Welcome back.
Let's go back to the phone lines at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty and
see if I have dealt with my audio issues.
We're going to go to our caller from the six
zero nine area code.
Who's calling today from six zero nine?
Yes, it is.
Hey, David.
Drop resistance.
All right.
You've gone completely underwater, so unfortunately,
I'm going to have to let you go and we'll
have to try someone else.
Let's go to our caller from the seven oh three
area code.
Who's calling today from seven zero three.
All right, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
OK.
Yeah.
Your audio, is this block better?
So, hey, David, I was just wondering, you've
mentioned a lot the a large problem the U.S.
has is not being respected by our allies.
Yes.
And also wondering how you would get people
specifically like on the right to prioritize
that, because a lot of people know that.
I know don't really think that, you know,
we should be respected or, you know, don't
really think it's worth it.
They don't care anyway.
Yeah.
Well, it's not that they don't care.
They know that it's like, you know, they're
actively, actively don't want to be like respected
as a country, which because they just think
that Europeans and Canadians like to hate
them.
They're like, why should why should they even
bother?
You know, like, how do we how would we like,
in theory, get rid of that?
Yeah.
I mean, some of some of them actually see
it as a badge of honor.
They're like, why do we care if the Europeans
like us?
We don't want them to like us.
That means we're doing what's good for America.
I mean, listen, I hesitate to ever recommend
trying to appeal to the rights values because
their values are often so misguided.
But I wonder, would the right care more about
the U.S. being respected around the world
if they saw it as a national security issue?
Like if they if they were convinced that we
are safer by being respected around the world,
then maybe we could get them to understand
the importance of not being a laughing stock.
I don't.
I mean, I'm thinking out loud here.
I don't know the answer.
Yeah.
Because, I mean, look, before you actually,
you know, try in theory, like get respected
by the rest of the world, which, you know,
in reality it's mainly just Europe.
You have to, you know, convince people that,
hey, this is actually something worthwhile.
And I think, you know, you have to do that
for us to put half the country doesn't co
actively, you know, doesn't really want to
be respected.
I mean, you can't really.
You can't really now pursue a policy that,
you know, get the U.S., you know, respected
around the world again because, you know,
it's just kind of fruitless.
I totally agree.
I mean, you have a city.
So so, for example, you know, on climate change
under Donald Trump, the U.S. is increasingly
not even invited to take part in some of the
important multinational conversations that
are happening about that.
But that doesn't bother the right.
You know, a huge part of the right thinks
climate change is a hoax.
Another part of the right believes that the
U.S. can just fix every problem by ourselves,
a sort of isolationist mentality.
So we don't need to be part of these multinational
converse's multilateral conversations.
So you are 100 percent right that if they
don't care, it's not going to be any.
It's not going to be a bargaining stick.
If they don't care about being respected to
begin with.
Well, I appreciate the answer, David.
My pleasure.
Thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you